à l'élection présidentielle de 2012 il a
reçu aujourd'hui l'assentiment du
Conseil national du Parti de Gauche en
revanche il n'est toujours pas le
candidat du Front de Gauche bonsoir
Jean-Luc Mélenchon merci d'être avec
nous ce soir vous n'avez pas changé
d'avis vous êtes toujours candidat oui
oui je propose ma candidature parce
qu'il faut respecter le l'ordre des mots
je la propose au Front de Gauche au NPA
au Front de gauche et ma famille hein le
NPA bon je suis accueilli assez assez
fraîchement oui oui bon bah on va
discuter et puis j'ai dû respecter un
calendrier celui du Parti communiste
celui de mes alliés mais surtout je
voudrais que si ma candidature intéresse
et semble être un point d'appui bah que
ceux qui ont envie qu'elle aboutisse
viennent m'aider voilà alors c'est vrai
pour la France métropolitaine mais
surtout je pas oublier l'outrem ou aussi
il y a beaucoup de gens de gauche qui
sont perdus en quelque sorte et qui ont
besoin d'un point d'appui vous êtes
prêts physiquement pour genre de combat
et mentalement parce que tous les coups
sont permis souvent dans une
présidentielle on l'a vu déjà avec
effectivement les réactions de certains
comme Maxime Gremetz qui dit que vous
êtes un peu le coucou du Parti
communiste vous êtes venu dans le nid
vous êtes installé puis maintenant vous
espérez récupérer le PC oui bon alors il
y a des choses plus ou moins sérieuses
qui se disent c'est vrai qu'il faut une
bon la résistance du caractère je pense
ne pas en manquer mais aussi je suis
comme tout le monde il y a des fois des
coups qui passent entre la chair et l'os
et il font très mal c'est vrai vousz pas
les petits arrangements politiques
pourtant il va falloir un peu s'arranger
avec le PC avec nég choisi non le PC a
choisi une méthode extrêmement
transparente ces militants vont voter
donc moi ça me convient parfaitement et
finalement pourquoi pas avoir fait de
primaire comme vos amis vouses amis
socialiste des primaires tout le monde
aurait voté soit Jean-Luc Mélenchon soit
Olivier besancenau ça aurait peut-être
été plus simple peut-être mais ça ne
s'est pas présenté et puis je suis pas
sûr que ce soit la bonne méthode pour
être honnête moi je suis entré dans le
dans dans dans ce combat là parce que je
dis franchement je me suis senti en
quelque sorte porté par des événements
enthousiasms comme ceux qui se passe en
Tunisie parce que le modèle de la
Révolution citoyen en Tunisie du SGE
vous choquez je trouve j'espère je parle
pas d'un risque pour moi c'est une
chance j'aimerais qu'il passe la
Méditerranée parce que nous aussi nous
avons une oligarchie alors elle est
peut-être bien sûr pas caricaturale
comme celle qui entourait le président
Benali avec cette tribu familiale mais
nous avons la bande du fouets nous avons
98 personnes qui détiennent les 43 % des
pouvoirs de vote du CAC 40 c'est des
grandes entrepris plutôt l'élection
plutôt que la révolution tout de même et
ben pour moi c'est conciliable voilà je
pense que comme en Amérique du Sud comme
vous le verrez en Tunisie parce que ce
que demandent les gens en Tunisie c'est
des élections et qu'est-ce il demande
des choses qui ressemblent tellement à
ce que moi-ême je dis que j'en suis
émerveillé là par exemple une
constituante c'est le premier point de
mon programme parce qu'il faut quand
même bien qu'on en finisse avec cette
monarchie ou bien un partage des
richesses c'est ma position un mot
rapidement de vos examis socialistes
parce que faut rappeler vous avez été
ministre du gouvernement je pas c'ta en
2000 c'est quoi c'est une erreur de
jeunesse cette épo non pas du tout c'est
au contraire quelque chose que j'ai mené
avec loyauté mais ça participe au
parcours politique bien sûr il faut être
capable de de tirer des enseigns ce
qu'on a vécu moi je je ne suis pas dans
la simplification il y aurait les pures
d'un côté les traîtres de l'autre la vie
vous présente des circonstances vous les
réglez d'une façon ou d'une autre et
puis il faut en tirer des leçons moi
j'ai tiré la leçon de notamment de de ce
qu'a été cette erreur d'aller mettre les
deux mains les deux bras dans la
construction de l'Union européenne
libérale qui conduit les socialistes à
être maintenant complètement
aligné vous parlez il y a pas de pure il
y a pas de traite tout de même si un
jour il y a des divergences par hasard
au deuxème tour il faudra choisir
peut-être si vous nêtes pas qualifié
pour ce second tour entou mais déjà on
pourrait quand même parler de
l'hypothèse où je suis qualifié donc la
question que je vis poser au socialistes
c'est de savoir si eux à ce moment-là
seraient prêt à se désister pour moi
parce qu'ils le font pas dans les autres
pay F pas dans l'autre sens au cas où
vous ne seriez pas au second tour il y
aura peut-être Martin auri ou Dominique
stroscan vous avez des préférences
j'imagine des préférences je je serais
mal placé moi d'aller me mêler de d'un
parti de la différence entre Martin et
mais si il y en a moi je n'ai qu'une
chose à dire pourquoi vous dites Martin
auri il y a aussi François Hollande il
aussi manuel Vals il y a aussi Arnaud
Montebourg bon vousêtes pas un candidat
de cœur non moi je dis seulement une
chose si les socialistes font l'erreur
de nous proposer le directeur du FMI ils
vont rendre le rassemblement de la
gauche quasiment impossible et quoi que
j'en dise moi si je montais sur la table
pour dire écoutez j'ai changé d'avis les
gens diraient bah pousse-toi de là parce
qu'on ne veut pas t'écouter regardez ce
qui se passe dans des pays comme la
Tunisie et vous comprendrez qu'en France
les gens n'ont pas besoin qu'on leur
tienne la main pour comprendre et savoir
comment de quel côté ils doivent aller
il y a c'est fini le temps des cheptels
électoraux et donc moi si je veux
convaincre entraîner aller à ce grand
bouleversement civique citoyen que je
propose et bien je dois être continu
dans mes opinions je dois être ferme et
si je dis on va faire le partage des
richesses et qu'on va titulariser tout à
l'heure vous aviez un sujet vous passez
les précaires de la de l'éducation
nationale si vous croyez que c'est
normal qu'on enseigne au nos gosses avec
des gens qui tous les ans se demandent
s'ils vont retrouver du travail d' après
s'ils ne sont pas dans un état ner qui
est insupportable et bien moi je dis je
réponds voilà si je suis au gouvernement
tous les précaires des trois fonctions
publiques seront tous titularisés parce
que il y en a assez de la peur du
lendemain voilà mais ça on peut pas le
faire avec la politique du FMI merci
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui monte en régime
voyez au fur à mesure de l'interview je
voyais la colère le bruit et la fureur
qui reviennent on verra ça tout au long
de la campagneici le bruit la fur oui la
colère non vous m'avez pas vous avez pas
été déplaisant du tout hein ben écoutez
merci à vous je le serai peut-être un
autre jour on verra on parlera de ça ou
quand on parlera du fond peut-être que
là merci d'être venu sur ce plateau il
est 20h19 à suivre